So back then we were collecting, they were doing the crimes,
they got sent to jail because you could only convict the guy who did the crime,
even though I sent the guy to go see a guy in a different way.
It's even different way. Yeah. Yeah. That's how we benefit. It's funny too.
And also in the fear city, a documentary, I remember, um,
John was talking about something about how, when Rico, when it came on the news,
and then they, they saw that like, you know, the, this guy was convicted,
that guy was convicted or Castellano got convicted. He's like, you know,
we were trying to figure it out. Like,
we're a couple of Harvard graduates told me, you remember what? He said?
That he was like, everybody, all of a sudden, he said, all these,
all these wives guys, they went to Harvard all the time.
And they're telling me about this or that. I was like, that was funny too. Yeah.
I mean, you can just picture him going, like he talking to smuggle. I got like,
you know, I know you went to Harvard and all that. You went to Harvard,
but I mean, let's be honest if you like sucking too. Right.
And it's what I mean, that comes with the pack. Would you picking up a buck?
What is the podcast? Can we get you on any lights, podcasts,
and promoted a little bit here? Why not? We're going to have to do something.
We gotta do something. You know what? Let's, whatever his podcast name is,
let's reach out to him and say, you should change the name of the podcast.
Do come see me in a different way. Oh, Johnny light and gene Borello.
This is the guy, Jean Borello. If you look at the Vlad TV,
go Vlad, TV, uh, put in John, [inaudible] the pocket,
the bolt these guys were on. And I guess we're doing a podcast together.
I bet you, the podcast is fascinating. The Johnny and gene show,
because can we listen? Can we, can we just at least hear it?
We don't get to see her at a couple of minutes of it or,
or can you just want to see we not how funny if he turned it on,
he was talking about if he was talking about dining room funkshway I'm in,
he's like, Hey, what's up? This is John. Welcome back. The name of the podcast.
Studios, concrete pot. I mean, the kid is still Jack. He will hurt you. Okay,
wait a second. He'll crush. This kid. Who's this Democrat.
What the is going on here? We got to get on this guy's podcast.
Did he say, Hey, I got a job for you. How did he hear?
This guy, this guy will hurt you or hurt you bad.
Yeah.
I mean, these guys always talk about truck loads.
Eight a day, a day in the life of a guy who was a soldier for the mafia.
At some point during the day he's tall. He's going to say the word truckload,
truckload, dude,
the guys in the mafia ever just have to dip into a Rite aid to get some clarity
and take their blood pressure. Do you think these guys ever were like,
you know what? I know we got a job. We got to cut this guy up. But my,
my I'm sneezing, my sciences are crazy right now.
So can we just stop and get a little clarity and decongestant and maybe just no
decongestant cause the ticket just to raise my blood pressure.
That was the funny thing. When they, when, uh, you know,
I was listening to this other documentary where they said they were,
they would tap the social club of John Gotti and others before or whatever.
And he said, you think mobsters conversations are real interesting,
but a lot of the time it's it's so it's even more boring because they
know it or suspect they're being tapped. So the guys would talk spaghetti,
endlessly. The mafia started in 1920s.
That's when it really kicked off.
That's what really kicked off in the United States. I mean,
it was going on in Sicily for awhile. I,
and I think it's still relatively prevalent in Sicily.
I think just in the United States, you don't really get if we go,
can you go up a little bit? You're kind of like, yeah,
they're just kinda like imitation Greeks, but kinda like not the real deal.
You know what I mean? Like they just, we, we like, we sh we should have,
we shouldn't have, we did,
which was create logic and reason mathematics because the Italians just took all
that and just started Robin. They just.
They just know a way to just kind of catch a break. I know there was a, um,
I forgot what it was, but now a lot of people have done it.
There was a restaurant,
I think in little Italy that there was like a squid shortage with calamari fresh
calamari, which is a tragedy in the Italian tragedy. Calamari,
there was a stew at the great calamari shortage of 97. Yeah. The calamine,
when they ran out of one of the, one of the mafia,
footsoldiers found out a way because the price has gone up in, in, in,
in squared for whatever reason that he just was like,
he started putting pig anus and making it look like calamari and throw drones a
rumor. No, that's real throwing that in red sauce. And then that,
so now a lot of times when you go to like a not classy Italian place,
they'll have calamari imitation. Calamari is pig,
and some mafia footsoldiers guy there found out how to do that.
That's an example of an Italian guy. That's an Italian,
you got a good sense of humor. Now,
ex example of Italian guy screwed in and make a calamari in a different way.
Yeah. And then you have very smart businessmen. There was the, um,
the man Michael franchisee, who was also in fierce city, documented,
also did a Vlad TV interview. Very, very famous guy.
He was like the businessman of this,
all I believe it's Michael franchisee was making something like $5 million a
month doing just business deals. And you watch him and you're like,
you and you listen to him. And you're like, this guy is so beyond intelligent,
but he'll also come out you in a different way. If, if you know, yeah,
here it is. Fear. Fear city is one.
I personally thought it's one of the best things Netflix has put out in all of
quarantine. It's great. And if you want,
I feel down the Sicilian mafia into one sentence,
it's basically that they say, Hey, we're here to do business.
We are going to do it this way.
And if you don't abide by what we want and how we want to do it,
we will see you in a different way.
I think anything in real estate waste management,
the docs in New York or New Jersey, it's all still to this day.
Somehow mafia owned somewhere.
Donald Trump is mov it's mafia money. That's right.
He didn't get those buildings from his dad. That's mafia stuff that put those.
There was an era where if you were doing any building in New York,
you had to deal with concrete companies and unions and work.
And yet they were all in that. Um, and then, and the mafia got broken up. The,
the, the star of the show who really broke up mafia,
who had their tentacles in all these legitimate businesses.
And they were extorting everybody. Like you said, like with the trash guy,
what he's doing is he's eliminating the competition. What they basically,
the mafia is like, that is what the mafia is,
is we'll come see you in a different way. Do business with us, give us money.
You can't really boil down the mafia better than that sentence will come soon.
A different club scene, a different way. That's the name of, so,
and that's going to make that a t-shirt too.
We're going to come shooting it there for them, seen a different way.
And then you go guess who's going to come see us in a different way for using
his saying and your money. Yeah.
We really hope you enjoyed that episode. Whatever it was about.
This is just a stock thing that we're taping on temporary episode.
So go make sure you rate, review us, subscribe,
turn on your notifications,
get jiggy with it and go to patron.com/bay Ridge boys,
where things get really wild. Huh?